I've lived in this area my entire life.
Right on the United States border.
Just a half a mile
across the river from Detroit.
I've been a scuba diver
and a diving instructor for over 25 years.
I was a broke university student
and it was the only place I could dive.
Because of wind and waves
the visibility is very limited, so
usually less than five feet and sometimes
as little as one foot of visibility.
So when you can only see this far
in front of your face, it's going to limit
the people who are actually going
to want to do that dive.
There is a very strong current
in the river
and it can really drag
you down the river quickly.
It's an extremely dangerous
environment, to say the least.
I found that every single
dive was an adventure.
You could find bottles and cars and
boats and shipwrecks and guns.
And it just hooked me
and I’ve continued to do it
until this day.
I was speaking with a local diver.
He said he had found a vehicle
that was upside down,
laying in the middle of the Detroit River.
And it was something that
definitely should not have been there.
Since this was not something
that was well known.
I wanted to follow up and see it
for myself.
Now, remember,
with only a foot of visibility
in the river, it's easier said than done.
I do a search pattern, so you just do a
zigzag on the bottom of the water.
Just going back and forth
and just seeing what you can find.
I actually saw it coming out of the gloom.
Wooden spokes for a vehicle
that told me this
vehicle was very early.
At that point,
I did not know anything
more about the history of it.
I didn't know what kind of vehicle it was.
But I really wanted to try and find out.
I dove a couple of more times
and I used my underwater video
camera with a high powered light
to really document
and get this evidence together.
Just so I could try to build a model
of what I was seeing underwater.
And what I saw was amazing.
The vehicle was upside down.
It was buried in the sediment.
So all I could really see
was the bottom part
of the wheels.
I could see the engine poking out,
but I really couldn't see anything
more of the top side of the vehicle.
There was a wooden floorboard
and there was a truck bed.
So very quickly, I determined that
this was not a car at all.
It was actually a truck
lying close to the back was a heavy chain.
We also saw a crank handle
on the front of the vehicle.
You would actually have to crank
that motor to get it started.
So the truck was old enough
not to have an electric starter motor,
but what kind of truck was it?